il faut qu'on aille magnifique
tableauire souffrir des hommes prend
la qu'est-ce que vous faites
là Jérém volatilisé me dire que vous
alliez braquer un tableau à 5
plaquesabitude faites les manteaux dans
les
barisoir je vous présente céleste Siméon
notre meilleur détective je vous
en c'est ma
mère je croyais qu'elle était morte et
ben moi
aussi j'aiis ce plan crée dans le côtin
siil se cache dans ce trop perdu c'est
parce qu'il a encore le tableau tu es
sur ton tuyau parce que c'est cafard ici
hein c'est le moment de faire entrer une
pièce rapporté dans la famille c'est pas
une pièce rapportée c'est ma nouvelle
copine j'ai mon frère Sam s'il te plaît
non mais qu'est-ce que vous faites ici
là c'est quoi ce tableau quoi ne me dis
pas que tu lui as parlé du tableau je
dis ce que je veux j'ai l'âge je suis
grand mais on la connaît pas cette fille
si ça se trouve c'est un
flic tu es Jale parce que tuas pas
d'autre plan tuas rien d'autre j'ai pas
de plan mais j'ai j'ai 1000 plans à la
minut qu'est-ce que tu crois mais c'est
quoi là c'est Mad et son fils il ont
l'air de bien
s'entendre coinc là vous pouvez faire
[Musique]
confiance jusquau bout de quoi Sam de
quoi tu parles c'est pas un bonjour pour
tirer sur quelqu'un pour moi il nous
enfum P
Mar qu'est-ce qu'on fout là on est
ensemble tu vois je te l'ai dit je est
peut-être en train de me embobiner
[Musique]
là